isn't evidence silent in space as alien
told us years ago in space no one can
hear you scream how can we talk about
the sound of the Big Bang if there's
nothing there for the Big Bang to make a
sound in in the very early days of the
universe what you have is instead of
having a uniform disapper fect a uniform
distribution quantum mechanics tells us
we can't have that perfect uniform
distribution definitely fluctuations on
those tiny tiny fluctuations it's like a
lumpiness of a soup but they even be
sound what you need are pressure
variations and those how are those
pressure variations set up right at the
start what you have is this soup this
plasma electrons quarks we haven't even
got atoms about 400,000 380,000 years
after the Big Bang what happens is that
everything cools down sufficiently so
that atoms can start forming before that
the issue is actually you can't see
through the universe because you've got
this dense fog this plasma tiny tiny
quantum fluctuations right at the start
get blown up very very rapidly and those
tiny fluctuations what they do is they
imprint pressure variations across the
early universe and when we look and see
the Cosmic Microwave Background it's
telling us about those pressure
fluctuations and pressure fluctuations
tell us about sound so you could say
that actually everything that there is
the entire universe the matter around us
arises due to sound arises due to
pressure fluctuations and what happens
in the Big Bang at least in the early
stages it's at that moment that instant
is you don't have those pressure
variations everything's moving out
radially at the same rate actually it
was silent which seems really why would
we call it the Big Bang if it's silent
why would it be silent one important
thing is to really have sound well what
is same sound is a variation in pressure
those fluctuations those pressure
variations kicked in rather later on a
little bit further down the line from
the Big Bang so the Big Bang itself is
probably best not to call it the Big
Bang it's probably best to call it
something like a big light rather than a
Big Bang
the density of the universe in terms of
the matter in the universe was a million
times greater a million times greater
than it is now so the best way to think
about the universe at that point in time
is that it's all atmosphere it's all
just its it's all air effectively it's
all atmosphere we know today that sound
can travel through space why can't sign
through travel through space
simply because the density of the atoms
isn't high enough to allow those sound
waves to propagate but right at those
early stages the density was beyond high
enough for sound waves to travel across
the universe so it's much the same as
you have standing waves and then you
have harmonics on a guitar string that's
the way you've got to think about it in
terms of certain patches of space will
have a higher density certain other
patches of space will have a lower
density so it's clumped together here
and then falls away and then you have
regions where there's a lower density
and then you can think of having one
harmonic having higher harmonics in
terms of how that matter is distributed
I don't see how this has anything to do
with sound but what is sound so again if
we think about a guitar string when you
pluck that guitar string you get a
standing wave set up on that what's
happening is that you're getting that
string is moving back and forth it's
moving air molecules back and forth and
they're hitting Europe your ears what's
happening there it's a pressure there
you go you've started something
propagating it's not the guitar string
that is sound
it's the propagation of the air being
pushed by the guitar string it is yes
but if what we can do is we can
interpret that that pattern that we see
we can interpret those harmonics in
terms of well what is what is happening
is that the density is being pushed
around
the density the the the matter is being
pushed around and you're getting
variations in density
you get in variations in density you've
got means you're getting variations and
pressure that is sound that is sand so
there is stuff moving we stop moving yes
yeah yeah yeah but but again the best
ways so why do we call it a standing
wave on a guitar string because it's
it's a wave that although the string is
moving up and down where is the maximum
it's always located at the right point
if we talk about the first time on it
gets right at the center of the string a
human ear
from here what kind of listening to us
so the problem is is that we're talking
about frequency so if we pluck a guitar
string I don't know we're talking by
frequencies of tens of Hertz to hundreds
of Hertz we're talking about periods of
a few seconds a few tenths of seconds
you know hundredths of a second when it
comes to the Big Bang we're talking
about 10 to the minus 12 Hertz or ten to
the minus thirteen or better way of
thinking about that it's 50 octaves
lower than when you pluck a guitar
string so we listen to a guitar string
you know that that's oscillating back
and forth pretty rapidly if it were the
Big Bang and we were thinking about the
oscillations for the Big Bang then that
string is moving up and down it's taking
twenty thousand to two hundred thousand
years to do one oscillation that's what
we're talking about so that's not just
heavy that's not just subsonic that's
sob sob sob sob sob sob sob song it's
sonic that's that's completely outside
the realm of any type of human
perception Phil I always think if the
Big Bang is a time of incredible energy
and velocity and violence and yet you're
talking to me about things that are
moving at these sub glacial speeds
absolutes it's bizarre isn't it to the
language we there's another example of
where we use language and physics and we
borrow everyday terms which don't quite
capture does it have a note is that like
a b-flat oh that's so you can in
principle work out where that note is
but the problem is that when you look at
the spectrum instead of having very nice
peaks frequency Peaks as you have with a
guitar string where you can see it you
know what's B flat or whatever the
problem is with the with the big bang
when you look at the spectrum of the big
bang actually those Peaks are very broad
which means that the note isn't isn't a
well-defined musical note it's much more
a much broader and much less distinct
what's more indistinct actually I'm
borrowing an awful lot of this from a
guy called Mark Whittle at the
University of Virginia he's got a
wonderful wonderful website where he
describes the what he calls Big Bang
acoustics others have looked at this as
well and if you go to his website then
you can actually find wave files sounds
where he's taken this spectrum
supposed it to update 50 octaves to
where we could where it's within the
range of human hearing and you can
listen to wide range of different
aspects of the sounds of the big bang
would dogs hear the big bay dogs
wouldn't hear the big bang not unless
they live to be 200 thousand years old
[Music]
you look at the Cosmic Microwave
Background that's tell you about
temperature variations but those
temperature variations as you said also
tell you by density variations those
density variations in turn will tell you
about pressure variations and once
you've got pressure variations then you
can work out how many decibels the Big
Bang was what we have is something
called a bell what a bell is is a
measure of the relative loudness let's
put it that way I'm being a bit loose
with words relative loudness of two
signals and the way that's defined the
Bell is log to the base 10 it sorts a
logarithmic measure and the reason we do
that is because our ears work
logarithmically and what you have is
let's see it two signals P 2 and P 1 and
this is the power of signal 2 and this
is the power signal 1 what we need is a
reference and let's use slightly unusual
subscripts here so let's have a loud
signal which we're going to Denis it
with that subscript and that's a
required signal and we're going to
delete that with that subscript now this
quiet signal is a reference signal
that's taken to generally to be the
limit of human hearing now we can
quibble about what that is and there's a
lot of quibbling about those but that's
defined in terms of a certain pressure
which represents the limit of human
hearing that's a bell however what you
find is it's better to work in decibels
just in terms of the magnitude of the
numbers involved so decibel we defined
slightly differently like this but it's
exactly the same idea that's in terms of
the power of the signal this is a
certain point and a technical point but
I'm gonna put it in there because
otherwise I know the whole comment
section will erupted so what would you I
was going to convert this from a power
to a pressure and those are related one
is the square with the other so that
gives us a factor of 2 when it comes to
the logs and what we end up for a final
formula is something that looks like
this DB is 20 log where this is our loud
signal and this is a quiet signal
I can fit it all on the page so normally
in air what we do is we'd look at the
limit of human hearing in air and think
about what the pressure is associated
with that and then we think about what
the pressure is associated with how I'm
speaking here ratio the to get the log
multiplied by 20 that gives you decimals
to give you an idea or what sort of high
end of decibels might be if you're
standing about I don't know 20 or 30
meters from a jet engine record the
sound coming from the engine I can
convert that to a pressure scale then if
I take that pressure reading from the
the jet engine compare it to the
pressure associated with the absolute
limit of human hearing that lads as a
logarithm to the base 10 multiplied by
20 that gives me by 140 decibels
that's 140 decibels is as I say quite
noisy and getting to the limit of human
here and turns out that the loudest rock
band loudest heavy-metal band on the
planet it's a band called Man O'War
which some of you might be familiar with
if you're not familiar with man who
looked them up hours of endless fun you
know Brady I can see you nodding your
head you know I had to get a heavy-metal
reference in someone they lay a clam at
139 DB to be the loudest band on the
planet they couldn't quite beat a jet
engine but that's pretty good but
actually if you stand just a little bit
back from the jet engine it falls off as
the inverse-square so depending on where
you are with the jet engine Manowar
could be louder so mana 139 DB let's run
that off that's all good physicists in
court should call that hundred and forty
to eighty B but about the same level in
terms of DB as a jet engine now you may
think well this is the big bang there
big bangs just going to be billions of
DB actually you look at those pressure
fluctuations you do exactly what we're
doing here of course your reference
level can't be within the soup right at
the start of the universe it can't be
the limit of human hearing but what you
can do is you can get the average
pressure from the from the pattern from
the Cosmic Microwave Background and then
look at the fluctuations about that if
you look at the fluctuations in pressure
well actually all you want to do is you
have a reference level and then you're
looking at the variation about that
reference level that's what were you
doing when you think about the jet
engine so obviously we can't send a
human back and also it's you know
happening on ridiculously long
timescales
we need something artificial so we could
set up a robot we'd have forget the time
machines order Dido Brady that's the
first thing and I've been working on
that for quite some time now and it
doesn't seem to be going in anywhere
fast but let's say we got the time so we
can send this robot back 13.8 billion
years or so and then what we need to do
is we'd have to set it up with an
artificial ear and artificially I would
have to be tolerant of fairly extreme
environments but we could set it up so
it's reference level would be whatever
that the baseline pressure is and then
we'd look at which tree it would know of
they would be programmed to look at
fluctuations about that baseline level
yeah thank you here we know the
fluctuations we know the level of the
fluctuations remember all we want is a
ratio so if we know those fluctuations
are at the level of ten to the minus
five ten to the minus six ten to the
minus seven
you know one part in a million one part
in ten minute and 100 million whatever
that's that's all we need to get a DB
value with a Big Bang well it's the
origin of every wouldn't that just
absolutely blow your head off wasn't the
volume just be could you exist you know
what it not just all sound waves just
completely brought you turns out it's
not as loud as we think it is so the
number when we work this through we look
at the decibels and we look at this
these variations in pressure
turns out about 120 decibels that's all
so not only is a jet engine louder than
the Big Bang Man O'War is much much much
louder than their don't than the Big
Bang our robot would come out and say
exactly how everyone if you enjoyed that
video then you're definitely going to
enjoy this it's a new book by Phil
Moriarty who you've just been watching
it's cold when the uncertainty principle
goes to 11 or how to explain quantum
physics with heavy metal in fact the
video you just watched is partly based
on a very small section of this book
I've been reading it it's really good
fun it's written like Phil speaks it's
enthusiastic it's funny I've really been
enjoying it I especially enjoy all the
footnotes Phil puts lots of jokes and
unnecessary detail of the footnotes
it's almost as fun as the book itself
and another reason you should check this
out is the illustrations all the artwork
in that were done by Pete McPartlin who
animates loads of the videos on sixty
symbols and number file including the
one you just watched
I'm really really happy for Phil and
Pete they've made a really great thing
and if you want to show them just a
little bit of thanks for all the time
they've given us in these videos over
the years consider this one when the
uncertainty principle goes to 11
I'll put links down in the description
or you can just pick it up at your
bookstore just look for that it's coming
out really really soon you can't miss
that cover can you this is what it looks
like when Phil holds it he's almost as
bad as me isn't he